papers allegations of voter regularities
and a conflict that's denied hundreds of
thousands of people their right to vote
abby ahmed has described the poll as
ethiopia's first attempt at free and
fair elections
major opposition parties have boycotted
monday's election while some who remain
in the fray say ballot boxes were
tampered with and their staff were
attacked
from addis ababa mohammed reports
there were long queues of voters in most
polling centers in several cities across
ethiopia
including in the capital arizaba some of
the voters started queuing as early as
4am local time
the electoral commission had increased
the number of polling stations across
the country
to avoid large crowds from gathering at
polling centers
to reduce the risk of spreading covet 19
but also to hasten the voting process
it is the first electoral test for 44
year old prime minister abi ahmed
who rose to power in 2018. championing a
democratic revival in africa's second
most populous country
and a break from its authoritarian past
[Music]
things are calm and orderly so far but i
just wish the process was a little
faster than it is we hope this election
will bring peace and unity
more than anything i will vote for a
party which i think will bring peace to
our country
and i have finalized my decision on who
to vote for there were delays in some
polling stations though the ethiopian
national electoral board says about a
dozen polling stations opened late
due to officials arriving late voting
was extended in some polling stations
to allow voters cast their ballots the
prime minister's newly formed prosperity
party is the frontrunner by a
considerable margin
in a crowded field of candidates mostly
from smaller
ethnically based parties more than 40
parties have fielded candidates
but most originally based some
opposition parties are boycotting the
vote
in the battleground state of oromia
opposition parties have boycotted the
election citing intimidation
and imprisonment of some of their
leaders and supporters
some opposition leaders have however
endorsed the process
calling it somewhat credible my
expectation is that it would
hopefully with minor difficulties would
be completed in a credible way
that's what we are hoping that what we
are watching very closely
up to now the turnout seems to be good
people are
out in big numbers to vote that's a good
thing that's a good sign
despite being billed as a nationwide
contest ethiopia's elections are not
taking place in one-fifth
of the country's 547 constituencies
elections in the somalia and hara
regions of eastern ethiopia were
postponed until september
for what the electoral board called
logistical reasons
elections are also not taking place in
the tigray region
of northern if you appear most of the
delayed votes are scheduled for 6
september
but no debt has been set yet for a vote
in tigray
the polls are being monitored by
observers from the african union as well
as a number of ethiopian groups
but the european union did not send a
team blaming ethiopia
for failing to guarantee the
independence of its mission
once the votes are counted national mps
will elect the prime minister who is
head of government
as well as the president a largely
ceremonial role
muhammad al-jazeera ethiopia